i'm fully expecting that upon release of
the film
uh there will be a second wave of
critical hatred for
the film which is again one of the
things that has happened not just to
your film but it's happened to nearly
any film these days that does anything
that crosses
the woke i mean we i i recently had a
conversation with jd vance author of
hillbilly elegy about how the critics
went after hillbilly elegy
and just burned it to the ground because
the idea behind hillbilly elegy was that
you might want to take some of these
rural white folks seriously and the
critics had decided in the meantime that
nope you know after the movie got
greenlit now was not the time to take
real white folks seriously we couldn't
do that anymore and they decided to just
burn it all the way down so what do you
think is the answer to that because we
are seeing this this
vast gap emerge between what the critics
think about films and what the audiences
think about films
hillbilly elegy has 20 some percent on
rotten tomatoes it's got an 85
approval rating among audiences i'm sure
that run hide fight will have a zero
percent or five percent or 14
on rotten tomatoes and the audience
ratings are going to be above 90 what
what in the
what in the conservative community
should we and the more mainstream
community should we be doing about those
i would love to take
biden at his word for unity but it's
never going to happen
it's not happening so i really believe
that
it's it's possible for both sides to
work together
to get along and to make movies and work
in the same workplace
i totally believe it's it's possible but
i also think we're entering
into probably an eight-year period
of tribalism and people sort of going
into their own corners
and i think that if people want to watch
movies like this
and continue to consume content
that isn't preaching a message to them
and
jamming a sort of a secular worldview
down their throats
then they have to support a conservative
economy
and by that i mean everything a
conservative hollywood alternative
any of it right so i think ultimately
uh you know it it it has to
i don't like it i don't i didn't want
this to
i thought i was going to be you know
living in l.a running a movie studio by
by now
and here i am uh you know in my own
independent lane but in a way i'm
happier now
than i ever would have been there and i
know those people
they're still my friends they're unhappy
they're insecure they're confused about
the lockdowns and living in california
under gavin newsom
they're confused about all this they're
moving to texas they're calling me
even my sort of lovely liberal friends
and and i'm encouraging them get out
and it's across the board if your
company
is pushing a critical race theory on you
get out of that company if you're going
to a college
and your professor is pushing an agenda
on you
speak up and push back now i know
i have a privileged position because of
my stature
and my financial situation and things
like that so i understand it's tough
but i promise you we will create enough
infrastructure
on the other side of the fence to give
landing pads
and and and uh places to work and make
movies
for people who don't want to work in
that industry anymore
and i'm still in the industry right now
i've got a movie at new line
that they say they're going to make this
year i sold a movie to netflix
it's coming out in a couple of months i
i've got a movie with uh
you know the folks who made john wick i
mean i i'm still
in the business right i talk to the
agencies all that all the time
so i'm still one foot in one foot out
but if i had to choose today
i'm out and i'm going this direction and
i'm so excited about it i think it's
going to be a big move
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content